Women go through a world of changes during
pregnancy...hormones fluctuate, organs move
and shift, and for many women, their libidos
go into overdrive with some saying their orgasms
are the best they’ve ever had…
But is sex during pregnancy safe for mom and
baby?
Hey it’s Natalia Reagan for DNews!
We got this great question from ---- on Reddit
who asked “Does having sex while you're
pregnant affect a baby's health or personality?”
This is ---- SECOND question, so excellent
job on keeping us employed!
And everyone else, please send us your questions!
First, there have been no scientific studies
on if sex affects a baby’s personality,
maybe just ask your parents.
But, we can answer the question of if it’s
safe for mother and child.
First let’s talk about what happens during
pregnancy and how the baby is protected from
the world at large, including a prodding penis.
A fetus develops in an amniotic sac filled
with fluid inside a woman’s uterus.
This resides behind the cervix at the end
of the vaginal canal.
About a month into pregnancy a thick, gelatinous
mucus plug is formed and fills the cervical
canal and contains anti-bodies to protect
the fetus from infection.
Thus, no matter the size of your tallywacker,
the fetus is well-protected.
Which is a good thing, because studies show
women get extra randy while there’s a bun
in the oven.
In a report from “The Journal of Sexual
Medicine”, 40% of women interviewed said
their sex drive increased since getting pregnant.
Which again, might be a good thing because
not only is it safe, there are actual health
benefits to boning down.
Doctors have reported that sex during pregnancy
can have a calming effect, help women fall
asleep, AND lower blood pressure.
And some women have even confessed that they’ve
experienced more intense orgasms while pregnant.
These O-mazing climaxes are thought to be
because the pelvic region is more sensitive
and engorged in blood during pregnancy.
Additionally, during orgasms there is an extra
release of oxytocin, AKA the love or cuddle
hormone.
Oxytocin has been shown to help build trust
in relationships so getting busy can also
strengthen bonds between partners during an
already stressful time.
And it’s not just the act of sex, it’s
also the byproduct that can be helpful.
A study done in Denmark found that a unique
protein in semen could actually help reduce
a woman’s risk of developing pre-eclampsia,
a potentially fatal illness that affects 3-5%
of pregnant women.
The illness develops when the placenta doesn’t
get enough blood.
The seminal protein helps to regulate the
body’s immune system, thus lowering rates
of preeclampsia.
Now, in the past there had been concerns that
having sex while pregnant would potentially
induce preterm labor.
And while the release of endogenous oxytocin
and the pro-taglandins in semen do aid in
the ripening of the cervix, there’s no evidence
that sex directly affects the Bishop score,
which is the scale used to determine if the
cervix is ready for vaginal delivery.
Even though sex while pregnant has many benefits,
there are instances when abstaining from intercourse
is recommended, particularly when it’s during
a high risk pregnancy.
Women who have previously gone into early
labor, or if their water has already broken,
as well as those who have a compromised cervix,
placenta previa or have a herpes outbreak
or feel one coming onare warned to abstain
from sex.
Obviously this is different from woman to
woman and if you have any questions about
safety, just talk to your doctor.
Despite these potential complications, pregnancy
sex is considered safe, fun, and beneficial
for most women- so get to it!
Just because you’re housing a nutrient sucking
parasite doesn’t mean you’re shouldn’t
be scragging, screwing, bumping uglies, whittling
the love branch, sticking the llama’s head
up the lift shaft, jamming the clam, thacking
the ferret, laying pipe, bending her over
a barrel and showing her the fifty states,
gallivanting in the Bridget’s bushes, or
making love…
What do you think?
Have any more questions about sex?
Let us know in the comments, on twitter or
Reddit and we’ll try to answer them for
you.
Now that we’ve answered this salacious pregnancy
question, here’s Trace debunking 5 other
pregnancy myths!